hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast touch in top 10 genetic test
countdown I am Judy O'Rourke of lab rats
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's virtual meeting is
presented by lab roots calm the leading
social media site for science
professionals before we start there are
a few instructions we want to hear from
you during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers are welcome to you can
do this by hitting the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can want a better look you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button on the top right or use the Q&A
button we'll make sure we try to resolve
any issues this is an educational
session and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the virtual
meeting is over please click on the c/e
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits now
let's get right to today's presenters we
are proud to welcome Catherine around md
PhD professor in the Department of
Pediatrics in chief of the division of
genomic medicine at UC Davis and Robert
Nussbaum md clinical professor at the
UCSF School of Medicine and chief
medical officer of envy tape corporation
dr. Owens presentation is titled top 5
pediatric genetic tests dr. Nussbaum's
presentation is titled top five adult
genetic tests dr. Rowan is
internationally known for her pioneering
work in the application of array CGH in
clinical genetics and as a leader and
major contributor to the understanding
of the recipes the rafts map Cape
halfway genetics syndromes her research
program involves the clinical and basic
science study of cancer syndromes with
effort to identify underlying genetic
abnormalities affecting common
developmental and cancer pathways
dr. Nussbaum a board-certified internist
and medical geneticist specializes any
care of adults with hereditary disorders
he was previously chief of genomic
medicine at the ucsf medical center and
helped direct the program in
cardiovascular genetics and the cancer
genetics and prevention program at UCSF
doctors Rowan and Nussbaum's complete
BIOS are found on the lab roots website
I will now turn it over to dr. around
for her presentation thank you so much
Judy thank you so much for that
introduction I'm just going to pull up
my slides here for the group and let's
get started with the top 10 genetic
tests countdown so here is your first
case presentation for the top 5
pediatric tests you are the physician on
call in the newborn nursery of your
community hospital and you receive a
page that there is a newborn with
dysmorphic features and a heart defect
there are no prenatal records available
because the family is new to your area
and upon gathering the family history
from the mother you learn that the
maternal uncle of the newborn had a
cardiac congenital anomaly that required
surgery and then after physically
examining the newborn you very much
suspect a chromosomal abnormality so
what is the genetic test you would like
to order so you are suspecting a try so
me and because you are suspecting a try
so me in the newborn period this is
considered concern for a genomic
medicine genetic urgency so obtaining a
saito molecular diagnosis as rapidly as
possible will help assist you in the
appropriate clinical diagnosis and guide
your work up as needed to assess
additional malformations and help with
the prognosis of this new boring so you
could send a standard karyotype in this
case but it's really important to
consider a wrap
good interface fish tests and because
this has a turnaround time of 24 to 48
hours and is readily a bit available in
your institution and in your practice so
fish stands for fluorescence in situ
hybridization and it's routinely used in
genomic medicine a fish probe is a
targeted DNA probe that is fluorescently
labeled to identify a suspected
chromosomal abnormality and fish is
commonly used for looking for
submicroscopic deletions in syndromes
such as villo cardio facial syndrome or
Williams syndrome prader-willi angelman
syndrome and others it can also be used
to identify the origin of marker
chromosomes but most importantly in this
case it can be used to identify common
trisomies very rapidly but with a fish
probe you need to know what and where
you want to target so again fish is a
fluorescence in situ hybridization and
interface fish was developed for a rapid
turnaround on direct prenatal
preparations such as a mios or chorionic
villus sampling tissues and it's used
for counting chromosomes to either rule
in or rule out and employees for
chromosomes the chromosomes 13 18 21 and
the sex chromosomes x and y so here is
an example of interface fish so these
are your normal chromosomes here you've
got two normal chromosome 13 this is the
fish probe in green and you have
normally to normal chromosomes for 18
and this is the fish probe in red these
are normal cells but if an individual
has trisomy 18 you're going to see three
red fish sick fish signals indicating
that your patient has three copies of
chromosome 18 so you have now made the
diagnosis of trisomy 18 so overall the
prevalence of trisomy 18 is 1 in 2,500
prenatally so remember that's prenatally
postnatally the it's estimated that
about one in seven thousand live births
may have trisomy 18 and trisomy 18 can
be very difficult to identify and it's a
very difficult diagnosis to make in the
newborn period because the phenotype can
be so variable that's why it's important
to do interface fish if you're
suspecting trisomy the survival rate for
trisomy 18 is about 22 to forty four
percent at one month and then by one
year of age the survival rate drops down
to about one in ten excuse me about five
to ten percent so that's interface fish
this is your next scenario you are a
community primary care provider and a
new family to your practice brings in
their newborn for their first well baby
visit check out and they are scheduled
to come and see you in two weeks but
they've come in a day of life three
because they're concerned that their
child is not feeding well and is
certainly not as vigorous as their first
newborn and upon examination all the
vitals appear to be normal the child
does not look dysmorphic to you you do
not hear a heart murmur and the lungs
are clear neurologic examination reveals
a very floppy hypotonic neonate who is
an exceptionally poor feeder and upon
further history you determine that the
mother is an advanced maternal age and
asking about additional family members
and taking a history you find out that
there is no neuromuscular disorders
within the family history so what's the
genetic test you would like to order in
this case well when you're thinking
about your diagnosis there really is a
schematic approach to hypotonia in
infancy and hypotonia is a common
presentation to a potentially very
serious condition so syndromes that you
want to think about might include
central nervous system syndromes they
might include syndromes that involve the
nerves they might include syndromes that
involve the motor
ron's or the neuromuscular junction or
even syndromes that involve the muscle
itself so a diagnosis of hypotonia in
the newborn period you always need to
think about prader-willi syndrome and
Prada really syndrome is estimated to
cause a Prada Willy in about one in ten
thousand to one in thirty thousand
individuals worldwide and it's a very
complex genetic condition that affects
many parts of the body in infancy this
condition can be characterized by weak
muscle tone hypotonia in this case
feeding difficulties which you also just
saw on your patient poor growth and
delayed development and individuals with
prader-willi syndrome typically have
mild to moderate intellectual impairment
and they can have learning disabilities
as well so there are many molecular
causes of prader-willi syndrome so it's
important to know which test you
wouldn't want to order first the most
common cause molecular cause of Prada
worley syndrome is caused by a small
interstitial deletion of chromosome 15
cue and that is a small piece of
chromosome machine on the long arm arm
of chromosome 15 and this can be the
molecular mechanism in about seventy
percent of cases with prader-willi
syndrome the second most common caused
molecular cause of prader-willi syndrome
is when the child inherits two copies
from mom of chromosome 15 and this is
the molecular cause in about thirty
percent of individuals with prader-willi
syndrome so when you're thinking about
the test that you want to order and
think about methylation specific pcr
testing and this is a methylation test
that will pick up about 99% of the cases
of prader-willi syndrome and just very
quickly methylation refers to a chemical
tag that is added to your patients DNA
and it will identify whether the DNA
comes from mom or comes from dad and if
the methylated DNA is maternal in origin
there is one particular pattern on the
test and if the DNA is from dad or
paternal origin there's a different
pattern on the test and so this pattern
can determine where the DNA came from
and so in prader-willi syndrome if the
test reveals a distinct paternal pattern
meaning that this particular DNA is
missing from your test then the
individual has has prader-willi syndrome
meaning that the DNA was inherited from
mom only so that's prader-willi syndrome
and methylation testing your third case
a three-year-old comes in for a well
child check and the parents of your
three-year-old female patient complain
that their daughter never makes eye
contact is not interested in playing
with other children her age and just
seems to be in her own world you're
concerned about a diagnosis of autism
and send the child for
developmental-behavioral pediatrics
consultation they send you their consult
note back and they say you know this
child really needs to be worked up for
genetic etiology of autism so given
their consult note what is the first
genetic test you would like to order for
your patient so the first thing that
should come to mind is a chromosomal
microarray or CMA and a chromosomal
microarray really is just a fancy high
resolution karyotype and it's the first
line genetic tests for patients with
developmental delay or autism spectrum
disorder congenital anomalies or even if
a patient has both and what's really
nice about a chromosomal microarray is
that does not rely on isolating
chromosomes from your patient and in
fact it's a chip based platform so you
so DNA is typically isolated from the
white blood cells of your patient and it
has a chromosomal microarray may have a
potentially faster turnaround time than
a standard karyotype so there are lots
of clinical uses for a chromosomal
microarray
pediatrics and these can be for people
with their individuals with
developmental delay intellectual
disability multiple congenital anomalies
autism spectrum disorder as defined in
this case epilepsy epilepsy and seizures
heart defects a family history of
chromosomal abnormality marker or in
chromosomes if there's a suspected
deletion or duplication in your patient
unbalanced translocations and it's a
very good test order when you have
exactly balanced chromosomal
translocation in an individual but the
individual still has it I've normal
phenotype what's also really nice about
all ago chromosomal microarray is it can
identify long contiguous stretches of
homozygosity that can be seen in
prader-willi syndrome so you send a
chromosomal microarray and this is what
you identify you find out that your
patient has a sub microscopic chromosome
deletion on chromosome 16 p and that's a
very small deleted region on the short
arm excuse me on the short arm yes of
chromosome 16 and you identify that your
patient has a chromosome 16 p 11.2
deletion syndrome and this can affect
approximately one in 35 hundred
individuals in the population
individuals typically have developmental
delay or intellectual disability some
can have autism spectrum disorder and
individuals can be impaired in
communication and social skills as well
as delay in development of speech and
language they can also have recurrent
seizures and when you do a very close
physical exam on patients with 16p 11.2
deletion syndrome you actually might be
able to identify minor physical
abnormalities such as low set ears or
webbing between the toes and fingers
known as partial syndactyly and what's
really interesting about this region on
16 p is in the small deleted region of
600,000 of bases that this particular
region contains more than 25
so in this particular case a chromosomal
microarray is your genetic test of
choice so here is your fourth patient a
ten year old male was referred to you
because the school nurse noticed that
the child has these multiple dark
birthmarks and you see the child in your
office and notice upon a very thorough
skin examination that there are several
several cafe au lait macules and there's
also this diffuse freckling on the skin
you measure the head consumption
circumference and you notice that the
child has a large head size for his age
and also has some learning difficulties
in school nothing major but just some
mild learning difficulties and you're
concerned about a diagnosis of
neurofibromatosis type 1 so you send the
child right away for an eye examination
to look for Lisch nodules you know those
small hamartomas in the irish the report
comes back and noticed no Lisch nodules
in this ten-year-old but you're still
very concerned about a diagnosis of nf1
but the diet child is not quite meet the
clinical diagnostic criteria so you want
to pursue genetic testing to either rule
in or rule out your suspicions so what's
the genetic test you would like to order
so you are concerned about
neurofibromatosis type 1 and so you want
to order the genetic tests that that is
a multigene panel that sequences not
only the nf1 gene but its cousin
syndromes as well called the razz off of
these so you think back okay I remember
nf1 but I've never seen a patient with
nf1 and you remember that it is an
autosomal dominant condition about fifty
percent of the cases or spontaneous
mutations about fifty percent of the
cases are inherited and it's a common
it's a relatively common genetic
syndrome affecting about one and three
thousand individuals and you remember
that it's caused by haploinsufficiency
of the gene called neurofibroma meaning
one copy in the patient's genome is
missing and that there are NIH
diagnostic criteria that can be used
clinically so you remember the criteria
that you need to
the following the individual needs to
have six or more cafe au lait macules
and the size depends on the age of the
individual you also remember that inter
tritanus freckling or axillary in
grinnell freckling can be part of the
diagnostic criteria and that these
neurofibromas or those nerve tumors on
the skin are part of the diagnostic
criteria as well or somebody having one
plexiform neurofibroma also optic
pathway gliomas or those optic tumors
can be part of a diagnostic criteria and
your patient defined already does not
have those lists nodules or those iris
hamartomas that can be found in the eye
a distinctive osseous lesion can also be
part of the diagnostic criteria as
depicted here in this tibial
pseudarthrosis and what's really
important is because this can be an
inherited condition a first degree
relative with nf1 is also part of the
diagnostic criteria so the thing about
nf1 is it's now known to be part of this
family of syndrome called recipes and
the recipes have mutations in a common
signal transduction pathway called the
rass pathway and because of the common
path of genetic mechanism of the recipes
there really is a lot of phenotypic
overlap and nf1 can be very difficult to
diagnose now in the context of these
other recipes so the question is all
these genes all these syndromes would
which is the gene that you would want to
sequence so this is where gene panels
come in and the advent of
next-generation sequencing has led to an
area era of inexpensive and high
throughput DNA sequencing and this has
really had a major impact on clinical
care and these gene panels use this
next-gen sequencing technology to assess
inherited mutations in multiple genes
simultaneously and they are commercially
available now and next-gen sequencing
has allowed this parallel sequencing of
millions of short pieces of DNA
simultaneously and so these gene panels
allow us to test genes in parallel
without substantially
increasing the cost for the patient
leading to different clinical out of the
real algorithm in which all known
contributing genes can be assayed at the
first evaluation and so the advantage of
gene panels include a decrease costs and
improve efficiency it decreases the time
involved it decreases the number of
patient visits and it decrease the
number of tasks that are sent so you
find out in sending away for this gene
panel that your patient doesn't have a
diagnosis of nf1 but rather has a
molecular mutation in the spread one
gene a cousin syndrome of nf1 that
causes ligious syndrome so the last case
of your of your top five pediatric
genetic tests one of the partners in
your medical practices retiring and you
now have inherited a 14 year old patient
who has a very complex history of
congenital anomalies and of
developmental delay in autism the child
has undergone an extensive workup
including a chromosomal microarray which
we've already talked about fragile X
testing a full metabolic workup a brain
MRI and an autism gene panel which we
just talked about gene panels to date
there is no molecular etiology that has
been identified after a thorough family
history and review of the chart you are
still suspecting a genetic etiology so
what's the genetic test you would like
to order so you are now considering
whole exome sequencing and whole exome
sequence II is like running a gene panel
but you are now sequencing thousands of
genes remember our genome is the
entirety of our genetic material it
includes information of the genome
structure and regulation our exome on
the other hand is that portion of our
genome that encodes proteins and
functional RNAs which accounts for about
one to two percent of our genome that is
thought to be functionally relevant so
whole exome sequencing otherwise known
as wes is currently clinically available
whole genome sequence II is expected to
predominate in the future but this is
not currently available now so you
decide to send whole
excellent sequency and this is the
next-generation technology of sequencing
that interrogate the coding regions
regions as i mentioned known as our
exons in an effort to identify causative
mutation and this exome sequencing
provides coverage of about ninety nine
ninety-five percent of our exomes but
this remember is less than to a percent
of our genome so a simple blood test is
collected from your patient as well as
the patient's parents and this is known
as a trio a trios preferred but it's not
necessary because the genetic test if a
genetic change has been identified you
want to be able to determine if this
alteration is new to your patient or de
novo or if it's inherited from one of
the patients parents but if you come up
to a case like this it's best to send
your patient back to genetics for
genetics consult clinical geneticists
are very happy to assist you in complex
cases like this so you send for whole
exome sequence E and you've identified
now a de novo or a new mutation in a
gene called b-raf and b-raf encodes for
a cardio facial cutaneous syndrome so
you've now made a molecular diagnosis of
cardio facial cutaneous syndrome which
is now one of the known to be one of the
recipes so next dr. Nussbaum in the five
adult genetic tests thank you
II need anything hello everybody i'll be
speaking about some of the 5 top adult
genetic tests that are being sent today
before i begin i would just like to
cover a couple of general comments and
principles that you should keep in mind
when doing the genetic testing the first
is then I get my correct slides up so
let's do that first one of the biggest
mistakes that clinicians make with
genetic testing one of the biggest
mistakes they make is thinking that all
genetic test results will either be
normal or abnormal like an adequate this
is not the case because we actually have
three outcomes for most genetic testing
something that's either disease-causing
or is thought to be likely disease
causing a change that we're pretty sure
is benign or is likely to be benign and
then the third is what we call a variant
of uncertain significance that's a
change that we don't know what it means
we don't know how to interpret there
until a certain significance are the
source of I think one of the second
biggest mistakes of clinicians make with
genetic testing which is they see a
variant of uncertain significance and
they think that it is the
disease-causing and clinically
actionable that they need to manage the
patient differently and as I'll explain
in a minute this is not the case the
third biggest mistake the clinicians
make when faced with a genetic test menu
is they assume that for any one
indication the more genes you test the
better and I'd like to explain that that
is not always the case and this is why
first these are the five possible
outcomes you'll see on most genetic
tests not all laboratories use these
five criteria for characterizing a
change but this has been the
recommendation from the American College
of medical genetics and from the
Association of molecular pathologists
and most laboratories are using this
method of reporting on variants where
one and two is there either
disease-causing are likely
disease-causing three and four others
they're probably benign or they're
actually known to be benign and do not
cause disease and then the fifth is why
I described to you before which is a
mutation or variant of uncertain
significance a vos is not currently
actionable the track record is of
following up on these vuss at least in
some of the conditions that we've been
able to do that in large numbers is that
the chances are better than 5050 in fact
in some cases is high in a t20 that the
V us will turn out to be a rare benign
variant that we couldn't interpret
because it was so rare but as we
gathered more data it became quite clear
that there are lots of people carrying
this variant who did not have disease
and so most of us is not all but most
are you classified as being rare and
benign and that's one of the main
reasons why you do not consider a V us
to be clinically actionable on its own
merits the more genes you test the more
likely you'll have one or more vuss and
this is a real problem because vos has
introduced uncertainty in the mind of
the patient as well as in the provider
who's part of the test but will not
provide any elimination in the
illumination it's not going to change a
clinical management and the larger a
gene panel you order the more likely
you'll find the USS that you can't
interpret so for that reason I try to
recommend that people choose panels that
fit the indication for which they're
doing the test and not always go to the
largest available panel
now one of the top five genetic tests so
I'm going to talk about this today the
first is read ettore breast and ovarian
cancer second will be talking about
rinse syndrome which is a hereditary
nonpolyposis colon cancer third is from
Bethulia fourth is familial
hypercholesterolemia and the fifth is
hemochromatosis this is somewhat
arbitrary but i would say that these are
five of the tests that internists and
most doctors taking care of adults if
they're going to order a genetic test
this is likely to be one of the ones
they are likely to order later breast or
ovarian cancer counts for about five to
ten percent of all breast cancer and
about fifteen percent of all ovarian
cancer it's the most common form of both
reddit or erased and ovarian cancer and
it occurs in all ethnic and racial
populations it's an autosomal dominant
so you only have to have one abnormal
copy of the gene in order to have the
increased susceptibility and the
prevalence of carriers of heterozygotes
varies from about one and four hundred
across the u.s. little higher in Iceland
and is significantly higher among
ashkenazi jews one at forty and the risk
is not only for breast and ovarian
cancer although you can see here these
are lifetime risks for breast cancer a
second primary breast cancer could be in
the same dressed if best ectomy was not
done or it could be contralateral
ovarian cancer as well as male breast
cancer prostate cancer pancreatic cancer
and for brca1 and 2 and the numbers vary
you can see that there aren't specific
patterns is but for example if the
general population risk for breast
cancer is about 12% a woman is carrying
a brca1 or 2 mutation has a round of 50
to 80 or 40 to 70 % lifetime risk in
other words approximately four to seven
times higher risk of developing breast
cancer in their lifetime and it tends to
be earlier onset than a typical sporadic
breast cancer secondary breast primary
breast you can see up to
seven percent lifetime after the first
whereas you're talking about two to
three times higher risks if you are
caring of brca1 or 2 similarly ovarian
cancer significant increased lifetime
risk a for male breast cancer even
though the overall absolute risk is not
that great one to two percent for brca1
five to ten percent for brca2 it's still
many fold ten ten to a hundred times
higher risk then you would see in the
general population for male breast
cancer prostate cancer also increased
risk although not as substantial
relative to the general population and
pancreatic cancer also although absolute
risk is well down in the one to seven
percent range depending on which gene
and which mutation you're carrying it's
still significantly greater somewhere
between 2 and 15 times higher than the
risk in the general population not on
this table is also that there is a
increase risk for melanoma has been
reported and I also like to comment that
in addition to ovarian cancer fallopian
tube and primary peritoneal cancer in
one of the hallmarks of hereditary
breast and ovarian cancer as well other
genes have also been found to be
associated hereditary breast ovarian
cancer these are in addition to BRCA 1 2
and may increase cancer risk at least
twofold in some cases four to five fold
over that of the general population and
so that when you go and look at
obtaining a hereditary breast and
ovarian cancer panel you will often see
these additional genes are in the panel
as well and in addition you may find
even more genes even different genes
that in addition to these us that I show
you here those also have it I have a
demonstrated ability to increase the
risk in families but they are not as
well documented and they're not as
substantial and
effect as these genes what's been shown
by a number of different studies now is
that panel testing including brca1 and 2
plus these additional genes increases
the yield of a positive doula terious
mutation effect in HP and Hera trade
breast ovarian cancer families by about
fifty percent and so just doing brca1 to
you oh you'll be missing about a third
of the strong genetic contributions to
this condition suspect Larry breast and
ovarian cancer if you have an early
onset under age 50 if ovarian cancer is
present at all multiple primary breast
cancers breast and ovarian and
individual male breast cancer triple
negative breast cancer pancreatic cancer
would breast ovarian either in the same
individual are in the same side of the
family I've ghazi Jewish ancestry and
son with breast cancer someone who has
two or more relatives one of whom has
breast cancer under age 50 or three or
more relatives with breast cancer at any
age and of course if someone already has
a previously identified brca1 or 2
pathogenic variant in someone in a close
relative in the family these would be
all reasons for you to suspect hplc and
to consider genetic testing of course if
there's a previously identified brca1 or
2 pathogenic variant in the family you
may choose to test only for that one
change and not do a complete check of a
panel of six eight or ten or twelve
genes the diagnosis of hplc matters it
alters management you might consider
bilateral prophylactic mastectomy which
you might not do in a sporadic cancer if
you do consider breast conservation with
lumpectomy and radiation therapy other
strategies is prophylactic oophorectomy
might be considered and/or close
surveillance closer than one
ordinarily do for the contralateral
breast there's also been some indication
that pipe inhibitors are particularly
effective for brca1 two breasts and in
particular ovarian cancers these are now
in clinical trials and some data has
been published so to suggest some
benefit so knowing that a breast cancer
has developed in someone with a germline
mutation brca1 or 2 has an impact on
management and for individuals were at
risk do not have disease but are known
to carry one of these mutations because
you've tested them there's a whole
variety of altered surveillance
approaches one would take over and above
what one would do for a woman in the
population of the same age including
prophylactic mastectomy or over ectomy
adding breast MRIs to annual mammograms
and then there's a whole series of
others which are somewhat controversial
and our under discussion for example
ovarian cancer surveillance is difficult
to do and it's been hard to demonstrate
that there is a real reduction in
ovarian cancer mortality mortality by
simply implementing ovarian cancer
surveillance it's done I'm not saying
that it is incorrect to do so but I'm
saying that if controversial male breast
cancer there is really not much evidence
that mammography or MRIs should be used
although if there's gynecomastia or
there is substantial prank amor
glandular and breast tissue present in a
man that would be an indication for
using radiography otherwise self exams
and semiannual clinical breast exams
pancreatic cancer is very difficult and
we actually don't have any
recommendations for that outside of
ongoing clinical trials in a research
setting for melanoma we do recommend sky
skin and eye exams for brca2 mutation
carriers in particular since they're the
ones we'll have the higher risk although
there is also some increase for brca1 as
well and those exams are not invasive
and can be
extremely effective and then finally
management diagnosis matters because of
family screening once you find some when
the family is carrying a clear
disease-causing mutation that now
indicates the need try to to get in
touch with other members of the family
usually through the index case usually
through the affected individual but to
reach out to them offer them genetic
counseling offer them genetic testing
explain to them what it what it is about
and it's often quite quite effective but
it's also quite disturbing to a family
to be suddenly informed that there is
this diagnosis in the family and that
does genetic testing that may indicate a
substantial increase risk the sudden I'd
like to talk to you about is Lynch
syndrome Maria Terry nonpolyposis
colorectal cancer this has a number of
different cancer types many in the GI
tract but also in the urinary tract and
in the brain and central nervous system
I will not go through all of the risk
but as you can see from this column that
the risk and the mean age at onset is
substantially lower and the risk is
substantially higher for all of these
disorders compared to the general
population in particular for colon and
Demetrio cancer substantial increase
minutes for talking about 10-fold or
more increased risk the Lin syndrome
affects 1 2 3 / causes one to three
percent colon cancers and about point
eight to one point four percent of
endometrial the population prevalence in
1 and 4 40 so it is not a major cause
for these conditions but it is a major
cause of early onset and also of people
who are at risk for more than one cancer
then syndrome is caused by mutations in
one of five different genes the two
major ones are called 1000 x 1 + ms h 2
and what they are our genes are involved
in repairing mistakes that are made when
DNA is being copied this cell they're
called mismatch repair genes and you
need to do all five if you suspect win
syndrome
when should when should you suspect it
well based on family history three or
more family members two successive
generations affected with Lynch related
type cancers one or more violent related
cancers diagnosed before age 50 and make
sure that it's not a case of another red
iteri cancer syndrome but I cannot talk
about today called familial adenomatous
polyposis there's also another dimension
of wincing role and that is testing of
the tumor for abnormalities in mismatch
repair this can either be done by
looking at a signature or a change in
the DNA called microsatellite
instability or doing an using antibodies
to look for loss of the protein products
of the mismatch repair genes but just a
warning that not all tumors that are msi
hi or lack the mismatch repair genes are
the result of germline mutations in a
limb syndrome gene there's also somatic
changes that can occur particularly that
extinguish the expression of mlh1 so
that you can get either microsatellite
instability or loss of them which one by
antibody staining without it being due
to lynch syndrome and there's a
complicated decision tree which I don't
want to go into right now that can
address when tumor testing should and
can and is appropriately entered into
the decision-making from when to test
for Lynch syndrome and the part of this
is the Bethesda criteria that have been
used that tumors for individual should
be tested for MSI if the colorectal
cancer is diagnosed in a patient under
age 50 if there's more than one cancer
in a person if there's colorectal cancer
with em shi hai if it's diagnosed and
one or more first to be relatives with
the Lynch syndrome related tumor or two
or more first or second-degree relatives
with Lynch related to risk regardless of
age so these are the sorts of criteria
but I want to stress that as the cost of
testing has gone down these sort of pre
test criteria
the attempt to focus testing just on the
individuals who have the highest chance
of carrying these mutations those
calculations are changing and changing
over time because it's becoming less
expensive to test people and therefore
it's becoming more compelling to test
people who might have a lower chance of
carrying a Lynch syndrome gene because
it doesn't cost so much to identify them
so this is something to really keep keep
in mind and to keep abreast of this is a
rapidly changing field management
diagnosis matters an individual affected
limb syndrome full colectomy if they
have colon cancer with Ilya rectal
anastomosis is recommended and then
ongoing surveillance of directly they do
not recommend a segmental reception
because of the high risk of additional
polyps and additional cancers in these
individuals and you also need to be pay
attention to individual and ovarian
cancer in individual Green syndrome
which would not be part of the
surveillance or the management of a
patient who has a sporadic colon cancer
and there are recommendations here I
don't want to go through all of them but
it's on it's on the slide slide deck as
to which recommendations make sense in
which ones do we feel there's
insufficient evidence to really justify
the expense and the inconvenience once
again family screening once you make a
diagnosis and you find the gene mutation
you not have a key that will allow you
to test other individuals at risk
identify them before they develop
life-threatening cancers and intervene
and manage their Lynch syndrome
effectively family screening very
important thrombophilia farm Ophelia I'm
going to be talking specifically about
factor 5 Leiden and prothrombin mutation
because they're very commonly used and
there are a lot of laboratories that
offer them and I think this is an
example of where one really needs to
introduce a dose of real
into the use of certain genetic tests we
know that they're common three to eight
percent of the general US and European
population palembang also common they
are extremely rare however in other
ethnic groups particularly Asian African
and Native American populations it's not
absent but rare both increase the risk
of deep vein thrombosis but most
carriers never experienced a deep vein
thrombosis or pulmonary embolism so the
idea of screening asymptomatic people
for caring factor 5 Leiden or
prothrombin is not recommended
furthermore even if someone has a deep
vein thrombosis whether or not to test
for factor five linemen factor 24 flavin
is quite controversial because it
doesn't consider to affect acute
management or the long-term management
it's not a major determinant of
occurrence risk furthermore family
history is a more potent indicator of
the risk for a V of VTE in an individual
than is this test and if you test
negative for factor 5 Leiden orphan
prothrombin it doesn't override the
increased risk indicated by a family
history this is from a cochrane style or
knew that was done that's really quite
good but I would like to stress this is
for individuals who are carriers of a
single factor 5 Leiden or prothrombin
mutation the American College of
obstetrics and gynecology has
recommendations of different of changing
the management of a pregnant woman if
she is carrying two copies of a factor 5
Leiden mutation or two copies of the
performant in other words if she is a
homozygote so I'm not addressing here
homozygotes which are much rarer than
the common heterozygous that are found
in a few percent of the population so
therefore testing for them are not
recommended in for routine
during a pace for asymptomatic
individuals for people that are going on
oral contraceptives if someone's had a
beat of a venous thromboembolic in the
setting of a major risk factor like
surgery or trauma it's not a part of
arterial thrombosis an individual that
unprovoked VTE who are already receiving
anticoagulation it's not going to change
that it's not recommended as routine
initial testing during pregnancy it's
not part of routine testing and women
deliver current fetal loss or placental
abruption the American College of
obstetrics and gynecology it's quite
clear on that and routine testing of
unselected children the first episode of
VTE however i would like to sis to say
that testing for having two copies being
homozygote is part of the recommendation
for women during pregnancy or a
contemplating pregnancy who have had a
VT e in the past familial
hypercholesterolemia this is a autosomal
dominant individual to defective genes
indeed have an even more severe disease
we worried the prevalence for mrs.
underestimated some routine 152 a1 and
152 one and two hundred heterozygotes in
the population however less than 1% are
diagnosed in most Western countries and
children are frequently missed yet they
need treatment there are three genes
that are known but as you can see some
around twenty percent we don't actually
know what the genes are and when to
suspect it when there's extremely poor
cholesterol emia when is a clinical
history premature coronary artery
disease certain physical findings and
the family history there's a whole
series of different parameters family
history biochemical etc that one can use
to try to increase the likelihood that
you're dealing with familial
hypercholesterolemia but in fact doing
molecular genetic testing is the most
way to have a definitive family history
a definitive diagnosis of
hypercholesterolemia
it's important because twenty to thirty
percent of the relatives of patients
identified don't meet biochemical
criteria but would be detected by gene
testing and they still need treatment to
reduce life long exposure to LDL
cholesterol diagnosis matters the risk
for coronary disease substantially
increased we're talking about 10 13 15
fold increased over that of the general
population and this can be reduced when
they are put on statins although more
aggressive statin therapy and other
kinds of cholesterol-lowering therapies
will probably be needed in people who
have familial hypercholesterolemia by
genetic diagnosis and diet alone is not
going to work these people will need
medical therapy and family screening
important I'm going to finish up finally
with the fifth gene very quickly fifth
condition mo-cro mitosis in the in the
Western world is and do almost entirely
to mutations in one gene called HIV and
in particular in one particular mutation
in hf e which is called 16 282 tyrosine
hemochromatosis is a recessive you have
to have to abnormal copies usually of
the Sistine 282 tyrosine people who have
160 intuitive tyrosine and also have the
other mutation which is histidine 63 ASP
aspartate is much less likely to have a
clinical manifestation diagnosis and
testing elevated transparent iron
saturation of forty five percent or
higher serum ferritin concentration
above the upper limit of normal and you
need to have to pathogenic changes in
this gene and arts palpable chroma
ptosis the key here is that you know
chromogenic testing is part of the
management pathway you can see here that
if an individual has a transferrin
saturation that's above forty five
percent is recommended by the American
gastroenterology Society the next step
should be hfe genotyping so genetic
testing is a routine component
of hemochromatosis diagnosis and once
again family screening is important and
in people who are carriers is important
to remember that because the carrier
state is so common it's not unusual for
a carrier to have a sibling who actually
has two mutations so it's just because
someone is a carrier that doesn't mean
the rest of the family does not need
evaluation and with that I'm going to
stop and we're going to open things up
for questions excellent presentations
thank you for bringing that information
to us all before we get started with all
of your questions here's a quick
reminder about how to reach us today
questions can be sent via the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll get to as many
as we can and I'm sorry we're a little
short on time today this first question
is for dr. Rowan and it is in what
percentage of clinical situations do you
order exome sequencing for all
intellectual disabilities for
neurological developmental disorders
so with regards to ordering whole exome
sequencing we in genomic medicine are
very mindful of an algorithm with
regards to how we approach the
diagnostic workup for patients so it is
not the first line of testing that we do
for an individual with learning
disabilities it will be something that
we would start with a microarray first
as presented in this as presented
earlier and then look for other
phenotypic features that may or may not
be present and then consider exome
sequencing but i just want to remind
everybody that this is something that is
very carefully thought about it's not a
first line test at this particular
juncture in genomic medicine the next
one is for you dr. Nussbaum please
explain how the geneticist classifieds
me significance of a variant is found
also how can the clinician get a sense
from the report of likelihood that a
vuss disease-causing oh we use a variety
of approaches you use a variety of
approaches to classify variant we base
it on the following first of all has it
been seen before in people with the
disease and not in normal control
populations how frequently is a scene in
the general population what effect does
it have on the gene is it one that
clearly damages the function of a gene
or is it one that simply alters a single
amino acid has it been seen to be
inherited in a family along with the
inheritance of the condition what we
call Co segregation in a family are the
functional studies where someone has
actually expressed the gene with that
mutation in it
in a system such as cell culture or in
an animal model and all of these are
then used and integrated together to
come up with a general overall
impression as to whether this is likely
to be disease-causing or not the genetic
test report should have a description of
how the diagnosis of the variant how the
interpretation invent was made what
resources were used to determine if its
present in control populations or not
how frequently is it found in
individuals don't have the disease but I
want to stress that very interpretation
is the practice of medicine this is not
something that is done by a software
tool it requires judgment from
experienced people i would like to once
again thank dr. Rowan and dr. Nussbaum
for their presentations do you have any
final closing comments to share with us
very briefly
so I want to thank everybody for their
attention today and just remind the
physicians and primary care providers
out there that with regards to the top
five pediatric tests with regards to
rapid interface fish a chromosomal
microarray methylation testing for
prader-willi syndrome exone gene panels
and full exome sequencing you know these
are tests that are used commonly in a
pediatric practice and if there's any
questions or concerns that you have
about your patient with regards to
genomic medicine management always
remember to refer to clinical genetics
genomic medicine we're here to help what
my last comment would be too full one is
this is a rapidly changing field where a
new knowledge is being gained at an
astonishing rate and the technology is
changing very rapidly so keep that in
mind and that it's important that you
follow recommendations that are up to
date our current the second is that
laboratories that do genetic testing
should be ready and willing to consult
with a provider who has ordered a test
to explain how and why a variant has
interpreted in a certain way but
remember very interpretation by
laboratory is similar in many ways to a
radiological study that a radiologist is
reporting on they can make suggestions
they're going to recommend clinical
context but ultimately the laboratory
test is one important piece that you
need to join with your knowledge of the
patient and the patient's family and
family history to form a complete
picture on how to take care of your
patient
thank you this is an educational session
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the meeting is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits today's
virtual meeting will be available for
on-demand viewing through September 22nd
2016 you'll receive an email from us
alert anyone it's available on demand
and posted on lab routes comm you're
welcome to forward this announcement to
any colleagues who aren't able to join
in today you're also invited to join dr.
Allen and dr. Nussbaum and the
networking lounge in a few moments where
they'll be answering more questions just
go to the meeting lobby and enter the
networking lounge in the lounge there is
a live chat feature where you can type
in your questions if you asked a
question in this session it will not
transfer to the lounge so you'll have to
reenter your query thanks for logging on
and participating in today's broadcast
and next talk starts in about 30 minutes